welcome back so now we're talking about
observability and estimators okay so
before we were talking about
controllability with a and B now we're
talking about observability with a and C
and if a system is observable can we
build an estimator so that only given
measurements of Y we can reconstruct
what the full state of the system is for
use with full state feedback control so
this is kind of the diagram I want you
to have in the back of your head we have
a system with some measurements Y we
would like to have access to the full
state so we could do lqr but instead we
have to go through this calming filter
or this estimator to estimate the full
state and then pass it through lqr okay
now observability is very very very much
like control abilities in some sense in
terms of the linear algebra this is
there's some duality between the pair a
B and a C and so in particular we can
how do I want to say this so before we
were looking at this this
controllability matrix B a B a squared B
a cube B and so on and so forth
now we're going to look at this
observability matrix curly oh and that's
going to equal C see a see a square dot
dot dot all the way down to see a to the
N minus 1 where n minus 1 where n is the
dimension of my full state okay
so you'll notice and I'm just going to
write down here so you remember the
controllability matrix C was B a B a
squared B dot a to the N B and so to
some extent these are starting to look
very very similar except now this is
kind of the transposed version
version of this okay so if I for example
wrote down a system X dot equals a
transpose X plus like CY and u equals B
transpose X you would get some kind of
duality between these so I'll let you
work that out but you have basically the
same linear algebra for observability as
you do for controllability so I'm not
going to beat this to death like we did
for controllability
what I want you to know are there things
like a rank condition so the system is
observable if the rank of this matrix
equals n okay the the it's a row space
of this is now instead of the column
space if the row space of this spans are
n then the system is observable and in
MATLAB that's really easy to check I
look at there's something called OBS V I
give it a and C this builds this matrix
and then all I have to do is look at the
rank of that observability matrix so
it's exactly the same as controllability
except now we're making sure that the
rank of this matrix is its full rank or
span
RN okay so we want to make sure that
this row space spans RN if it's
observable then given any state X I can
back out what that state is from
measurements of Y so it's kind of like
the reach ability and controllability
this is really observability I can I can
estimate any X from a time series of Y
so if this is true then I can estimate
I'm just going to write it in shorthand
I can estimate X from Y and what we're
going to find is that this calman filter
is actually going to be its own linear
dynamical system and the eigenvalues of
that calm and filter are going to tell
me
how fast x-hat converges on to the true
state of the system X and so just like
we could do eigenvalue placement with
controllability we can also do AI ghen
value placement in the Coleman filter to
make this estimator go faster or slower
and the reason we wouldn't want this to
be arbitrarily fast estimation is
because maybe the system is corrupted
with noise and disturbances and if I
make this call mentals are too
aggressive it's going to overemphasize
noise and disturbances ok so there's
some balance just like there was a
linear quadratic regulator and the last
thing I want to tell you is that again
there is something called an
observability granion I'm not going to
write it out but it's very similar and
so that observability granion is a
square n by n matrix if I looked at its
eigenvalues and eigenvectors I'd figure
out not just the binary condition of if
the system is or is not observable but I
would get an idea of how observable the
system is and we can also look at the
SVD of this observability matrix so I
could say in MATLAB u Sigma V equals SVD
of this curly observability matrix and
of course I would literally just type in
OBS V AC here and now we care about the
row space of of this singular value
decomposition so now V the columns in V
or if you like the rows in the transpose
are in order the most observable states
in the state space so just like in
controllability there will be some
directions where it's easier to observe
given measurements why and when I say
easier I mean if there's noise if
there's measurement noise I'll get a
less noisy measurement of some
directions than others and so again I
can define this
kind of ellipsoid defined where the
principal axes are the singular vector
these right singular vectors of the
observability matrix or if you like the
eigenvectors of the observability Graham
Ian and what this tells me essentially
is in some directions I'll have higher
signal-to-noise than another so in the
most observable directions let's call
this c1
I'll have higher signal-to-noise than in
the less observable directions okay so
again what we're actually going to do in
practice is we're going to test the rank
of this observability matrix to see if
our system is observable to see if we
can build a common filter maybe we'll
look at things like the SVD of this
observability matrix to see what
corrections are going to have better
signal to noise and so on and so forth
and then just like in the lqr case we're
going to build an optimal common filter
that optimally estimates the full state
given the fact that there's going to be
some noise and probably some
disturbances on the system okay so
that's all coming up but for now I just
want you to know that observability
basically completely leverages the same
tools we have from controllability
mathematically they're basically the
same problem